good morning Hank it's Tuesday yesterday
was World Refugee day so I thought I'd
share a story of a family I met while I
was in Jordan move act nada and their
five kids mu was trained as a
butcher but he'd become a successful
entrepreneur in Syria but then he had to
leave everything behind in 2012 to
escape the fighting and after four years
in Jordan where refugees are not legally
allowed to work the family savings were
depleted but when I met them back in
February they were excited because they
were about to be resettled in the United
States specifically Rockford Illinois
you may have heard it's easy for Syrian
refugees to get approved to live in the
US but it's just not there are many many
layers of background checks involving
all kinds of investigations from iris
scans to fingerprinting to lots and lots
and lots of interviews in the case of
this family all told it took more than
two years but at last they've been
approved we've never been to the US
before you Fock told me we're very
excited we can't wait not a told me I
hope Americans will welcome us I hope we
do not disappoint you so a couple weeks
ago rosianna and I went to Rockford to
catch up with the family
Life magazine once said Rockford is as
nearly typical of the US as any city can
be you know it's the kind of place where
downtown there's a statue of a white guy
holding fireworks and an American flag
it was great to see the family again and
we enjoyed an immense and delicious
lunch together but the dislocation of
the move had clearly been difficult from
the language to the weather from the
healthcare system to the grocery store
to the appliances everything was
different
nada explained one profound change to me
in Jordan she said if we needed to go to
a shop we would find public
transportation here we have to have a
car or know someone who has a car she
began to cry as she told me she missed
her family and was struggling to get
used to life so far from them her son
comforted her and then told me mom also
cries whenever Messi scores everyone in
the family is taking English classes
MUFON will soon begin working as a
butcher the kids are in summer school
and starting to learn to read and write
in English in short the situation is
complicated and hard and hopeful like a
lot of our lives but I'd argue that in
every way socially politically
economically we are lucky to have this
family in our country to be a refugee is
to be politicized too often we're told
that because of their ethnicity or
religion refugees are threats that our
civilization
is fundamentally incompatible with their
civilization but of course that imagines
culture as a discrete unchanging unit
which it isn't and it also ignores the
facts the fact for instance that
American soldiers in the revolutionary
war included Yusuf Ben Ali and boPET
Muhammad and the fact that today more
than 3 million Americans are Muslims
from Dave Chappelle to the owner of the
Jacksonville Jaguars to my US
congressman Andre Carson nada told me
she hopes not to disappoint us
well I in turn hope we do not disappoint
her when I asked one of Natas nephews
who's been in the US for almost a year
what he liked most about his new home he
said the ball at first the translator
and I were both confused we thought he
was saying the Arabic word for God but
he was saying that or the law which had
not existed in Syria and which had
prevented him from working in Jordan was
what he liked most about the United
States his family did not come here to
change the law they came to be protected
by it
Hank last week UNHCR launched a global
campaign called with refugees asking
people to stand with refugees by signing
a petition calling on governments around
the world to one ensure every refugee
child gets an education to ensure every
refugee family has somewhere safe to
live and three ensure every refugee can
work or learn new skills to make a
positive contribution to their community
I hope you'll join me in signing that
petition there's a link in the dooblydoo
below and just one last thing
that statue in downtown Rockford of the
white guy with the flag and the
fireworks his name is Joe Marino his
parents immigrated to the United States
from Italy in a time when many Americans
believe that Italian Catholics would
their loyalty to the Pope could never be
real Americans participating in a
democracy and now Joe Marino is a symbol
of Americanist to the people of rockford
we contain multitudes which has always
strengthened us Hank I'll see you on
Friday